a little late on this review but what
can I say I like to savor you know what
I don't do you got a sip it you got to
enjoy it does that excuse what it worked
for the first couple weeks maybe not the
next couple weeks one is I want to talk
about spider-man abuse for now so let's
do it
[Music]
spider-man on ps4 yes it I have to say
that and of course it would be on ps4
but it's an amazing spider-man not
spectacular spider-man that's superior
spider-man it's just for warning you
when I start talking about the plot
there'll be some spoilers you've been
warned so Spiderman came out on ps4 it's
completely crushed everyone I knew was
playing it everyone who gamed online was
playing it I was playing it because the
game is completely addictive it more or
less follows the gameplay of the Arkham
games but for spider-man any game that
emulates Metro to Castlevania is known
as Metroidvania as its own format I feel
like for open-world action games Arkham
is going to be that this is an
open-world Arkham style spider-man game
in Manhattan you swing around Manhattan
you find little pockets of crime you go
deal with that you find some side
challenges you have your main story arc
maybe some surprise Spidey villain
cameos or characters that you might not
have expected and how when are can we
get more batman tech and this one to get
more spider-man tech you get more web
shooter abilities unlock abilities just
like in are can unlock combos just like
in Arkham there is a learning curve
there are a lot of combos a lot of
abilities that you can link together a
lot of moves a lot of possibilities you
have to do a Spider Man there's a couple
of groups you fight you're like this
game is hard but as the game progresses
you get better at it you become a badass
you start taking out these hives these
bases of baddies with challenges they
give you more points the biggest
learning curve in this game for me was
the counter mechanic same counter
mechanic as in Arkham only in Arkham the
triangle button was the one that
countered on the PlayStation in this
game it's circle so for the longest time
I was pushing triangle out of habit cuz
it's just years of muscle memory with
our commutes to unlock and spider-man
also I thought that was a great bit of
fanservice I gotta lie I unlocked Ben
Reilly suit I had that for a lot of the
games I don't even give a I like
Ben Reilly I like Scarlet Spider he's
awesome but not only that you have the
classic suit spider-man homecoming suit
the new suit for this game a lot of
suits I am a bit disappointed that the
symbiote suit the black suits not part
of it not in this game that would have
been a really nice bit of fanservice
that just isn't here why but every
costume you unlock gives a costume
ability and for me the most advantageous
one was the first one I started with the
one that refills your special meter your
special meter allows you to instantly
take out guys or refill your life this
is the best one but comment below let me
know which one was best for you the
story is great - this isn't spider-man
year one like spider-man homecoming this
Peter Parker this spider-man he's been
at it for about eight years now so he's
a bit of a veteran he's been at this for
a while he has a system down I really
like sizing this
Parker up at the Tom Holland Peter
Parker me like yeah this is years of
experience between the two this game
goes through a series and fillings at
first you take out Wilson Fisk and you
have mr. negative I don't know who mr.
negative is he's relatively a new
villain in the spider-man world
relatively I think he came out like 2007
or something like that I just didn't
really know much about him oh all right
well I'm taking on this villain I don't
know much about but the gameplay is
great I'm not attached to the villain
but fine mr. Negi is a guy who'll be
like my powers simple I make shadows
that I hit you with every shadow bombs
and I make shadow monsters and shadow
animals that are really big sometimes I
invade your mind and give you nightmares
like scarecrow from Arkham it's a little
confusing
really yes sure screw you too do I look
like an old man because a negative white
beard do I look like Malcolm McDowell
now you can't have any of my pot pie
but that's mr. negative what are his
powers really he makes energy he makes
shadows he invades your mind and gives
you nightmares he can control minds he
seems to be able to do a lot sometimes
it felt like Kitty Pryde in x-men Days
of Future past but it's like I can walk
through walls also I can send you
through time I don't know how one feeds
into the other I just not but that's
going on the first time I ever saw mr.
negative was this gay 90 Spider Man fan
like I said but really the meat of the
emotion it's the Doc Ock storyline I
thought forever I would always size up
any Doc Ock to the Alfred Molina Doc Ock
yes Otto Octavius in this game is the
quintessential Dachau it's a touching
story of someone's decline someone's
fall at a point you're like am I gonna
see Doctor Octopus in here because we're
kind of getting to the end of the mr-
story oh my god it's a sinister sixth
game it just really shows how Octavius
is brilliant that's his power and he has
the forearms because his limbs are
giving out on him he has I don't know
what he has a generative disease of some
kind in anyhow his muscles are giving
out so that's why he developed the
octopus arms why he relies on him why
he's so attached to him but it's a
really sad touching story of Peter
Parker's friend and boss just falling I
feel like we can never have Doc Ock in
the new spider-man movies because I
would always compare that Doc Ock to
this Doc Ock now there's sinister six
they don't have huge storylines and
there he just kind of releases them and
then you got to fight them in the form
of boss fights goes by pretty fast
obviously if you're just doing the
storyline there are enough side quests
to keep you busy in between some of the
bases of enemies that you have to take
out are harder than some of the sinister
six bosses and this is where in terms of
Story games have the upper hand over
movies if a spider-man movie had this
many bosses and this many characters I'd
be standing here going out too many
characters on screen
I felt really cramped in here but a game
can draw it out a game can have one plot
of bosses lead into the other lead into
the next an open-world videogame like
this is a prime format for telling a
comic book store and we have ourselves
some Miles Morales backstory like we
don't get the backstory to Peter Parker
spider-man because we know what we've
seen it we all we know but Miles Morales
you get his story and here's my
confession about Miles Morales let's
never really attach to the dude best
phrase is I never cared about Miles
Morales not that I disliked Miles
Morales there's kind of nothing Tim it's
kind of like a flash I know a dude who's
like Wally West was my flash not Barry
Allen meteor Parker was my spider-man
not Miles Morales I think it's great
people have a new spider-man but this
game makes me attached to Miles Morales
like if this is your introduction of
Miles Morales which for all intents and
purposes it is mine he's awesome he's
quite a good character I'm glad I saw
his origin story and I also cherry on
top love the fact that Jay jonah Jameson
is just talking in your ear with his
spider-man slander on the radio it was
great hearing the nonsense he was spat
out it was great having jonah jameson in
here is the only way they really could
you never go to the Daily Bugle so this
game missing jonah Jameson it would be
missing something special guys in the
end this spider-man game I love it I
don't want to call it the quintessential
spider-man experience but it very well
might be that I had never in any game
felt so like spider-man before the game
plays rock solid the missions are fun
some of the missions are really
frustrating lucky you don't have to get
Gold's on all of the challenges in the
game to get the platinum trophy for the
game I have a platinum in this game one
of the few games I have a platinum in
not saying that to boast that I have a
platinum but saying that to illustrate
the trophies the platinum is challenging
it's but it's not ball numbing ly
impossible that's how true fees I feel
should be that's how it wasn't doom
that's how it is in spider-man and I
appreciate that whether you're playing
to the storyline doing the side missions
or just going through the streets just
swinging through the buildings looking
for crime to stop his game his gold man
like I loaned it to my brother so we
could play it I'm already going through
withdrawal this game is set up for a
sequel I want to see where they go this
could be the next Arkham trilogy but
with spider-man spider-man is awesome
tacular
it's why it's not actually that great
that's a cool label the perfect for a
prop thank you for being patient I know
I'm not the quickest person to review
game so priority one take your time and
enjoy the game and so I did hopefully
you do too
alright so spider-man on ps4 have you
played it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]